تحت عنوان قطاع غزه 100 يوم من الياس في
خضم حرب طالت كثيرا جمع تقرير نشره موقع
ميديا بارت شهادات نازحين في رفح على
الحدود مع مصر حيث خيم مليون شخص على
الشاطئ يوسف واسماء وكثر اخرون محاصرون في
قطاع غزه حيث يعيشون من اجلاء الى اجلاء
مع عائلاتهم من الاطفال الى كبار السن لن
يستطيعوا الذهاب الى ابعد من رفح بسبب
الحصار الشامل الذي تفرضه اسرائيل واغلاق
المعبر الى
مصر راى الكاتب توم بينت في تحليل نشرته
صحيفه الاندبندنت انه مع تزايد الدعوات
الدوليه لوقف اطلاق النار في غزه ومطالبه
عائلات الرهائن الاسرائيليين بعودتهم الى
ديارهم وتزايد المخاوف من نشوب حرب
اقليميه اوسع نطاقا لا ينبغي لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان يتوق وقع سوى
المتاعب مع مرور اكثر من 100 يوم على
الحرب على
حماس قالت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان
بنيامين نتنياهو يواجه رد فعل سياسيا
عنيفا بشان استراتيجيه حكومته في ملف
الرهائن ويتعرض لضغوط متجدده لاعطاء
الاولويه للرهائن الاسرائيليين في غزه
واشار المقال الى دعوات زعماء المعارضه
وبعض اعضاء مجلس الوزراء الحربي والعديد
من الاسرائيليين العاديين الى اعاده النظر
في الحرب ضد حماس ووقف العمليات العسكريه
لتمكين اطلاق سراح الرهائن
نقل موقع المونيتور عن مصادر دبلوماسيه
اسرائيليه وامريكيه ان الازمه بين
نتانياهو والبيت الابيض تتفاقم وان صبر
واشنطن قد نفذ واضاف الموقع ان فريق بايدن
والمسؤولين في الدفاع والخارجيه يشككون في
عقلانيه سلوك نتنياهو خلال الحرب ويحذرون
من انه قد يجر اسرائيل والمنطقه الى حرب
شامله ختاما نقل تقرير نشرته صحيفه تايمز
اوف اسرائيل تحذير رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي هرت سي هاليفي من ان ما وصفه
بالمكاسب التي تحققت خلال اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر من القتال في غزه يمكن ان تتبدد بسبب
عدم وجود خطه لاداره امن القطاع بعد الحرب
وكانت التعليقات التي ادلى بها هاليفي في
الاسابيع الاخيره تعكس الذعر بين المحللين
العسكريين وغيرهم بشان عدم الاستعداد لما
يسمى باليوم التالي في غزه في الوقت الذي
تنهي فيه اسرائيل المرحله المكثفه من
حملتها العسكريه ضد حركه
حماس